welcome back to new rock stars the bat
signal is lit
and dc fandom is responding with huge
bombshells about robert pattinson's
batman
bat fleck resurrecting and the snyder
cut even
michael keaton batman in the upcoming
flash movie
uh philip has also heeded the call but
we are being told that his
bat suit has too many abs this is rogue
theory the podcast that brings you the
wildest nerdy hot takes on topics you
can't stop arguing about i'm eric boss
and with me today i do pitch rogue
theories are joshua ovenshire aka
joven that's right the king of theories
is back it's a self-proclaimed title but
i'm keeping it
all right someone will usurp that throne
if you're not careful so you gotta be
on your game today also joining us
friend of the show and twitch streamer
hey
trey angelica trey welcome back hey
hello
hi it's good to be back uh and returning
to new rockstars but first time on rogue
theory host of the only stupid answers
podcast our friend dj wooldridge welcome
back man
hey that's me hello all right guys let's
do this
dc's fandom is blowing the lid off dc
with big announcements from zack
snyder's justice league matt reeves
robert pattinson the batman movie coming
next year
wonder woman 1984 james gunn's suicide
squad
and it sounds like michael keaton
reprising his burton era bruce wayne
in a flash flashpoint alternate universe
for the first time in years
dc rumor brew is boiling over like an
uncovered database chemicals and
we're gonna dive right into it don't get
me wrong
all those all those dc movie news sound
great but let's not forget the fact that
we are getting some wb games
announcements as well along with some
ride squad the game and gotham knights
come oh yeah
we're getting it's all kinds of media is
going to be covered this weekend
it's it's an exciting time to be alive
but i want to hear from
you three some final bets on the eve of
the event
what do you think the craziest
announcement will be
from dc's fandom joven as the
self-proclaimed monarch of this why
don't why don't you dive in first ah
yes uh since they first announced the
schedule uh
my my brain was just going into uh bat
sense mode and i was like all right
we're gonna be getting
some pretty cool announcements and it's
a little difficult since it is a
digital uh event but how do you bring
that same impact that same wow
factor but in a in a digital stage and i
think we do that with some
major surprises uh one of which it will
actually include
uh the reveal of cast members that had
not
yet been mentioned now normally in in
hall h you get like the nice like
why don't we welcome blank and then you
know natalie portman comes out on stage
holding a thor hammer everyone's like oh
my god
that's right that's right we are going
to get a lot of conversations around you
know zack snyder's uh justice league cut
this is
the snyder cut but i think the biggest
announcement won't be
you know dark side footage or or even an
extra scene with deathstroke there
no it is going to be the reveal of green
lantern in the movie
as logging into fandom in three
two one chris pine's username pops up on
screen
and and chris pine is there as our new
hal
jordan not only will wind up in the uh
zack snyder uh snyder cut but then also
they'll be announcing his uh his his uh
role in the upcoming green lantern tv
show
now one would think wow chris pine you
can't really top that well guess what
folks
they aren't going to stop there the
theories keep coming as we realize that
there's other universes that need some
more casting choices and yes we are
talking
about uh maybe one of the greatest
batmans we've ever had in the 1989
batman movie
uh but one of the other best casting
choices in the tim burton movies
they're going to show up again as well
and you'll you'll have like your little
zoom meeting much like we're having
right now and then all of a sudden an
extra camera will pop up
and and it won't be any video just audio
you'll you'll hear like the mic
fumbling and someone's trying to get
there and then
and then you just hear wait is this
thing on what hold on
another camera loads and there he is mr
devito
dan knee devito as he says his
uh his big line from you know uh batman
returns
ah the direct approach i admire that in
a man with a mask
and then the e crowd goes wild as denim
devito
is is coming back to the batman flash
universe now of course it's not the same
timeline that we got in batman returns
but yet
we'll still be penguin alongside uh our
our 89 batman wow are we getting
catwoman too
uh not in this one sequel as we get our
our bat verse uh uh spin-off because you
know we've got the pattinson
uh uh timeline you've got the the bat
fleck timeline and now you're gonna have
michael keaton's uh timeline where you
know uh michelle pfeiffer
does come back as catwoman in the uh uh
also being announced batman beyond live
action movie
hey hey while we're at it wait so i
gotta follow up here jovan are you
saying that
uh chris pine uh how jordan
is it the same character in the wonder
woman universe or is it just like a
separate casting
it's separate casting completely casting
uh she might seem to be like oh you look
really familiar and he's like ah no
never seen me before
because i mean he is my hal jordan that
guy is like
perfect in that role if they could find
some kind of bonker's way
to tie him in it was like earlier on
there were some rumors of him like
actually being announced
in in justice league before the first
wonder woman movie came out and he was
cast in that so
weren't there also rumors of uh army
hammer was supposed to be uh
jordan at one point or another mm-hmm
yeah he was
also supposed to be batman at one point
in time so you know it's it's a very
like it's just a cast of people
and honestly with all the crazy things
that's happened with the dc eu
i don't think recasting chris pine in
this is too much of a stretch to be
honest
right i think it's even crazier that he
came back for wonder woman 1984
it's like we'll all find out in a couple
weeks exactly what is going on there
oh there's a bunch of theories around
there but uh that was super optimistic
and a couple we'll find out in a couple
weeks that was a really optimistic like
prediction like we'll
find out in a couple you weeks i also
want to be surprised if like you know
the ring
finds uh chris pine in wonder woman
right before the plane explodes pulls
him out of the ship and he's just been
in some kind of stasis on uh
the green lantern corps so that's the
way to go
uh well stranger things have happened
stranger things have happened
uh stranger things probably won't happen
by the end of 2020 but
uh i'll still have hope for that as well
um
as in the netflix show yeah i figured it
was like oh
yeah we all say um i'm gonna color code
your
theories with uh two green rogy sparkle
bucks
uh because that's two interesting
castings there of
bringing back danny devito for whatever
this this flashpoint movie's gonna be
hopefully
well it's because he like dies in the in
the pipeline and then just kind of keeps
on going
pipes eventually break he falls into a
lazarus pit and that brings him back and
that's why penguin is never really
disappointed that's the thing
yes in the in the dc world all pipelines
lead to lazarus
pits yes we all get to have our toys
that we had and we were kids all over
again
it's actually a big infrastructure issue
yeah yeah
there's there's a lot of yeah we gotta
work on it cross-contamination
plumbing is awful yeah and then all the
ace chemical vats are uncovered osha is
so pissed they don't have any proper
drainage going on
so anyway uh uh jovan what are your two
uh sparkle bucks turning into
uh uh i'm gonna be pulling those right
out of the uh internet screen and we got
a little uh switchblade that i got when
i was 18.
i thought it was so cool to have my own
little bucket knife
we'll have it to open boxes nice all
right
this is just the first thing that i can
grab with my right hand here on my desk
uh it's that
well i'm glad we're doing this from home
interesting theory jovan let's move on
to angelico what do you think is gonna
be the craziest thing to come out of
dc's fandom
okay so i'm glad that jovan mentioned
the snyder cup because i was thinking
that maybe there'd be something similar
to that announced this year at fandome
and i'm thinking okay um along the lines
of batman again because we all love the
batman
what if there was a schumacher cut for
batman forever
you're doing it you're pitching it oh i
oh man i
i heard some rumblings about that i want
to hear exactly what you think this will
be
well i i i heard that so schumacher
originally wanted it to be a lot
grittier and it's just going to be a lot
longer
but i think it's going to really dig
deep into
batman's psyche and how
like the come up of batman and i hope
there's going to be some more giant bats
involved yeah i don't know it's
something that i've kind of been hoping
for for a while and
i thought that the the cut was really
good like the original film and what was
it 95
but i would love to see just like a
darker grittier version
of how schumacher wanted it to be seeing
that film i can't imagine
anything left on the cutting room floor
but i think you're right there probably
is some stuff
uh and val kilmer comes out and he like
announces it and everyone's like
freaking out
oh man because val kilmer isn't he on
the the schedule right
we just did an episode of the big
question where we looked at we ranked
all the different uh batman
versions on in films over the years and
like
yeah falcom or batman did not rank that
high
but like he uh he's he's underrated i
would say he is one of the like the
brainier batman's
and i appreciated that about him he is
the smartest man in the room usually he
didn't make it above him no not at all
and there's a sizeable gap between uh
between kilmer and clooney i could see
robert pattinson's the batman
actually growing up to become vel
kilmer's version of batman
which is wild to think about because
robert pattinson is already a grown
adult
man like when you watch
how i met your mother and it's like but
you're not you're a grown-up you're not
gonna
grow into a different person like
sometimes like two years of a lot of
stress just really takes its toll
it's like the gap between ewan mcgregor
at the end of uh revenge of the sith
and uh alan guinness at the beginning of
new hope it's like wait what happened in
the past 15 years
hey when we were when we were kids
watching these movies those people will
always be grown man adults to us and
robert pattinson will always be like
uh the pretty boy in our high school who
we wish we were
so he's always there's always going to
be that age gap there but you are
totally
twilight right now uh i'm always talking
about twilight if you read between the
lights
i was like either twilight or harry
potter because i think that's that was
his like
intro into a lot of our lives yeah well
and i gotta say though because you know
obviously
robert panton has a lot of die hard fans
from twilight and god bless him every
time because all you know he was in lost
city of z
he was in good time uh he's been on a
lot of really good movies
giving really good performances and
every time i tweet one of those out all
the twilight fans show up and i'm like
look at robert panson
showing all like really good movies
yeah there's not a active contingent of
uh lighthouse heads on
on twitter yeah but i would love to see
i'd love to revisit batman forever i'd
love to see
that movie more explore his psyche
because i think that is something that
they did really well in the movie i do
wish um
you know the whole chase meridian
psychoanalysis of batman
more affected his um scene-to-scene
moves
in that movie i feel like it was just
something like here's our b story nicole
kidman and val kilmer are going to like
flirt about his you know she's
definitely going to be breaking
some hippocratic oaths by sleeping with
a patient probably
but uh no but like i i would love to see
that more influential throughout the
movie
so the production design doesn't so
overtake the movie and
tommy lee jones and jim carrey don't so
overtake that movie as they did in the
theatrical cut
rightfully yeah but i do enjoy your
theory i'm just gonna give you
one rogie sparkle buck uh angelica just
because i i think that
might be i think there's a lot of
loyalists to the batman
forever uh theatrical cut that would
come after me if i gave you any more
okay oh
i like it it's a cute little heart
thank you for that oh but it wasn't a
heart when i gave it to you honey
i didn't give her her heart it's still
pink it's okay
yeah yeah uh all right dj what have you
got for us what's gonna be the craziest
big thing announcement
so you said the craziest thing i want to
say like i think the thing we're
probably going to be talking about the
most is anything with suicide squad
obviously james gunn has a lot of um uh
fan devotion
um and i think yeah a lot of that movie
is still kind of shrouded in mystery
um but again going with the craziest
thing i think the craziest things that
could happen i could see a couple
scenarios one
i could see um the heads of time warner
coming out on a skype call and just
shredding dc comics in front of people
uh people online just cry uh i can see
another scenario where like
where like people are dying on and you
see ray fisher like oh ray fisher and
then on the same call you see joss
whedon and then on the same call you see
jeff johns
and then ray fisher just berates them
for like an hour and a half
okay but i think i think what we're most
likely to see that's the craziest thing
is i wouldn't be surprised since a lot
of these films were filming some of them
got a chance to wrap some of them did
not
um i wouldn't be surprised if we saw
some costume reveals
for uh penguin and riddler and catwoman
from
uh the batman i think the biggest of
those would obviously be catwoman if we
got a full costume reveal of catwoman
yeah
not just her biker outfit yeah because
uh uh you know riddler and penguin are
kind of notorious
notorious for mostly doing variations on
street clothes
um but i think if we got costume reveals
from that i think that would be pretty
big and pretty crazy
yeah what what's your um concept
uh head canon for the catwoman costume
dj well i think
uh darwin cook did a i think he was
responsible for one of the more modern
redesigns um that was kind of like the
the kind of um
it was an homage to like the m appeal
british avengers kind of cat
suit um that i've always thought in my
in my mind like that's catwoman's
costume
joel jones recently and her run on
catwoman just did
a a redesign that is pretty popular i
could see something like that but it
kind of you know they really like
you know it's it's dark and it's gritty
and it's grounded but like batman's
still
walking around in body armor so you know
like it's still like
um i i it'll be interesting to see
whether it's
it's closer to something like anne
hathaway's version
from uh dark knight rises which was uh
fairly practical all things considered
yeah or if it is if it is just like
literally street clothes and she's got
like cat ears on or something i would
imagine it's closer to a more
traditional costume
i'm hoping that there's a hint of purple
to kind of give us that uh yeah long
halloween
purple outfit vibe because that's like
the one that we haven't seen on screen
yet
i think that's gonna be the big question
with the matt reeves batman like
where is it gonna fall on that spectrum
between a functionality and aesthetic
because like
we've seen a really beautifully stitched
together
but not at all comfortable aware of your
michelle pfeiffer
catwoman suit um which is probably the
best of all the catwoman suits
it looks sick it looked great but i just
made sense
did they have to sew that on her every
day they did they did
yeah yeah yeah um so if it's gonna fall
somewhere
we've seen the two extremes we've seen
pure functionality for the most part
with the nolan one so
i'm i think with the bat suit every time
we look at these set photos or these
leaked images we're kind of like so how
realistic
is this world you know is it uh how how
do these weapons function how do
batman's uh gadgets
work uh in this world is it gonna rely
on them a whole lot
or is there some kind of like symbolic
costume that that's why they're wearing
uh but that i agree dj i think that
would be a very very exciting thing to
get some confirmation of it's just like
an idea of the production design of this
world um all right dj i'm going to give
you
one rogi sparkle book uh for your pitch
what does that turn into one here
i think what it turns into is since it's
just one it turns into this little uh
stargold lego i have
which i added to the set when we were
doing our star girl reviews only uh at
youtube.com slash only stupid answers
nice nice nice nice uh all right three
interesting theories we will be checking
back in next week uh to see who is
closest with the craziest i think it's
gonna be something that
no one saw coming i i mean last year
2019 at comic con i had no idea
herschel lee would be walking out on
that stage right so
i feel like this is dc's time to to
really
surprise all of us so i'm and if you
want to win over the internet you bring
out danny devito
so i look forward to this uh danny
devito
danny devito is basically the mahershali
of the 90s i think
we can agree i agree with that take um
all right before we continue we want to
thank some friends who helped us make
this episode
uh first our friends at manscape so uh
2020 has been the year of things
happening that are completely out of
control but there is one thing
you can control and that is how you
shave your pubes
um our sponsors at manscaped are here to
remind you
to do so and to give you a chance to do
so carefully
but cleanly so manscaped offers
precision engineered tools for your
family jewels the manscape lawnmower 3.0
is a premium electric trimmer that's
designed to give you
a confidence boost through body image
you might look more like henry viii than
henry cavill with your shirt off but
you can feel great about your body hair
situation
either way thanks to manscaped so let's
uh chat about this the lawnmower 3.0
has a 90 minute battery so uh if it
takes you
90 minutes to shave your nuts
you're covered you got a lot of nuts
there's a lot of
there's a lot of a lot down there uh
it's got an led light do you see that
that's a bat signal
for you uh it's waterproof so you can
shave in the shower or
a swimming pool if you don't care what
gets caught in the filter uh
they also just released their shears 2.0
nail kit which is a perfect add-on to
their lawnmower 3.0 trimmer the shirts
2.0 is a luxury four-piece nail kit
featuring tempered stainless steel tools
keep your claws
looking good even if they're not
adamantium that's a different comic
universe come on it's dc week
in fact listeners of the show will get
20 off and free shipping with the code
rogue theory at manscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
and use the code
rogue theory it's time to grab 2020 by
the horns
by shaving that front trunk also we want
to thank our friends at hydrant for
sponsoring this so
summer's here it's crazy hot outside we
all know that we should drink more water
but by the time you feel thirsty it's
too late you're already dehydrated and
you can't focus and
you feel tired and the blue dungeon
starts
covering all the surfaces and i need
water i need water hydrants here to help
hydrant has created a refreshing
electrolyte powder that you mix into
water to more effectively hydrate your
body it hydrates you quickly
and keeps you going for longer each
rapid hydration mix has the four
essential electrolytes that your body
needs and it packs a punch
to help your body hydrate fast and stay
that way and hydrate
is backed by research the formula was
developed by an
oxford scientist whoa
my god it is loved by pro athletes and
has thousands of five star reviews it's
made with real fruit juice powder
and comes in a variety of delicious
flavors including a new summer friendly
iced tea lemonade and fruit punch
actually before this i i did
the icy lemonade because you know on a
hot day i always love a good arnold
palmer flavor
so refreshing it was the perfect way to
beat the heat and even though it's not
really part of the whole hydrant package
i like to make it a john daly
until i can't say arnold palmer anymore
hydrant is backed by a 100 satisfaction
guarantee if you don't love it send it
back for a full refund but you're
probably
going to love it we've got a special
deal for our listeners to save 25
off your first order just go to drink
hydrant.com rockstars or
enter our promo code rockstars at
checkout that is
d-r-i-n-k-h-y-d-r-a-n-t dot com slash
rock stars and enter code rock stars for
25
off your first order drink hydrant.com
rockstars and enter promo code rockstars
to save 25
off and we want to thank them for
sponsoring rogue theory and lastly we
want to thank our friends at magic spoon
for sponsoring this when i was a kid i
don't know about you folks i
loved breakfast cereal it was the only
food i would eat on the weekend i would
wake up
i'd plop in front of the tv on saturday
morning to watch some x-men the animated
series and i'd have a big bowl of sugary
cereal and it was heaven
and then i would stay in my pajamas all
day and i'd go back to bed and i'd wake
up at a random time and i'd continue
eating cereal and i'd sleep with mystery
and make little forts and my cereal
boxes and it was my little world and no
one
was allowed in well i'm not a kid
anymore
um sure but my body does not respond
well to ingesting birthday cakes worth
of sugar first thing in the morning but
luckily
for me there's magic spoon cereal it has
zero sugar
11 grams of protein and only three net
grams of carbs in each serving
it's keto friendly gluten free grain
free soy free gmo free
there are four great flavors to choose
from cocoa fruity frosted and blueberry
i liked frosted the best because it is
the flavor of
the hair tips that early 2000's eric
wanted
but is told his brittle baby hair
wouldn't retain the bleach
um so i um would just look at
videos of lance bass and justin
timberlake
and dream and dream and i go back in my
cereal box fort
anyway magic spoon tastes great and it
has become
my go-to cartoon watching breakfast
because i'm still watching those
cartoons go to magicspoon.com
rockstars and grab a variety pack and
try it today and be sure to use our
promo code rockstars at checkout to get
free
shipping and magic spoon is so confident
in their product it is packed with
a 100 happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason they will
refund your money no questions asked
isn't that great
that's magicspoon.com rockstars and user
code rockstars for
free shipping all right we're moving on
to our discord rogue theory so every
week we play a game i broke there with
our friends and patrons on the new
rockstars discord
server this week we had some patrons
pitch theories about quentin tarantino's
proposed star trek film script
we had some fun theories this week from
the analog kid in unpantalone but our
winner was
sinister super spy they pitched a real
fun theory
that combined the multi-layered ensemble
plot of pulp fiction
with all the romulan and klingon
political maneuvering of star trek lore
he even squeezed some 70s music in there
how does that sound to you guys if
there's one thing that tarantino can do
really well it's a period piece so
if you give him a period piece that
takes place in the future i think you
gotta win
yeah i could see that and then they're
like cruising with some really good
music
in space oh that's such a good mix of
like future tech
and like kind of you know pass i dig it
i can see that
it'd be hilarious if there was because
there's several episodes of the original
series where they would just go to a
planet where it's like but this planet
is just like earth in the 20s
it'd be funny if their movie was just
literally like it's star trek but they
go to earth in the 90s and it's just
pulp fiction but with star trek
characters
uh well you can play along with us too
you can have your theory read on an
episode of rogue theory just by becoming
a patron
of new rockstars at patreon.comrockstars
and joining our discord it's a really
great community we have a bunch of cool
stuff that we do
uh with all of our friends there so
check that out all right let's move on
to our other topic we're talking about
suicide squad james gunn's uh suicide
squad
sequel but it's called the suicide squad
of course james gunn is constantly
posting on social media
but he's actually been pretty
tight-lipped about the plot of this
quasi-sequel we haven't
actually gotten confirmation on what
characters the giant cast that includes
john cena nathan fillion idris elba who
these people will be playing
uh but there are some speculative
theories out there that the reason
all these people were cast is we're
gonna have some kind of opening montage
where most of them are just brutally
killed off so i want to know from you
guys
pitch me which member of this new
suicide squad film
will be killed off first and dj why
don't you go first here
well i uh my overarching theory
is that i think a lot of the original
cast is not going to make it very long
in the movie to the point where i
actually think that might be the reason
will smith didn't want to do it because
they're like yeah we're going to be in
the movie and we're going to kill you
off like 10 minutes in and he's like nah
that's okay um yeah but if i had to pick
one if i had to narrow it down to one
person i think rick flagg
uh is done for him okay uh and i'm also
just generally shocked that he made it
out of the first movie
yeah yeah cause he seemed like uh
ripe to be cannon fodder um so i would
imagine that like like you said
opening sequence a lot of them are going
to be off just to emphasize
the nature of this team in a way that
maybe we didn't get in the first movie
um and and i think rick flag is one of
those that like oh he's part of the
original team so everybody's going to be
sad about it
but also we doesn't have powers we don't
really care so it's not going to be that
big a deal like it's not going to mess
up the plot that much if we off him
do you have like an imagined death
scenario for him
uh you know i don't know it kind of
depends on on what the mission is i
think there have been rumors that uh
this might
somehow tie in with black adam i feel
like at this point that seems like a
stretch
um so i would i would not be surprised
if we're
kind of presented with like um a a
combat scenario set in the middle east i
know the beginning of john ostrander's
run
um dealt with like an international
terrorist team of super-powered people
it may be cool to get homage to that but
like it could be just as simple as he
gets a bullet in the head
it's interesting you bring up john
ostern it seems like with the new logo
title design it seems like they're
evoking the john astro
ostrander era classic run highly
recommended very good all right dj
uh i am awarding you another one roguey
sparkle buck for you for your theory on
rick
thank you thank you and that becomes
something over here
i mean of course it does i know i know
what the rules are
sounds like there was a question yeah i
don't know what the rules are because
that's why i have
my little mario thing but the batteries
died on years ago
or or they haven't been sold yet because
i just got it from the butt
that's right that's right that's what it
is that's how science
that is all right um angelica who do you
think will be the first to die in the
suicide squad
okay so kind of similarly i was thinking
that
they might want to start fresh and might
kill off a lot of the characters from
the first film
but i'm thinking that if i had to choose
one
it would be captain boomerang and
i'm not sure but i kind of want to tie
in the australian theme here
so if there's like a kangaroo i know
there's isn't there like a marvel
kangaroo
i believe there is yeah okay i know we
can't really cross over too much with
that but like
something similar so he gets in the
fight with a kangaroo
or just like generally another aussie um
i'm here for it so captain boomerang i
think he's going to fall first
with james gunn there's no reason why he
wouldn't just have him fight like a
jacked up kangaroo
and then the camera wins i mean we've
all seen the image of the jacked up
kangaroo and we've all thought about
could i take this kangaroo probably not
exactly
no it's like this uh a lot less of a
funny
interaction i will say in the most
recent suicide squad squad comic
it is written by uh tom taylor who is an
aussie so they've kind of incorporated
there's like a resistance team made up
of primarily australian characters so
maybe
they're not going to show up but like
hey if you want to stick with the
australian theme you know
yeah let's just do it i would love that
task force or something and you know
watching birds of prey
i feel like the one other dcu character
that showed up in there
was captain boomerang right like there
was a wanted poster in the police
station
so if that's the one they kill off in
the in the suicide squad
would be super fun like they they set up
this idea that they're building a world
for him but then like jai courtney's
just like nah screw it kill me off you
know that would be awesome
um yeah all right uh angelica i am also
awarding you
a uh one rogie sparkle book only because
for both you and dj there are some of
these other cast members that i really
really want to see killed off with an
opening montage a bit more than those
two
um but i'm awarding you one okay perfect
let go of it look oh what
okay all right thank you so much oh it
came out it's a little um
star trek cat pin oh so cute
engineering kitty cute oh nice
thank you thank you for that oh you're
welcome you're welcome i didn't want to
part with it but
um you deserve it mine now yoink
or meown now um yeah forced it
didn't work regretting it immediately
bail me out here
all right oh i actually liked the idea
that you kind of like had like this
opening montage where people just start
dying i do think that there will be
something maybe akin to that or even in
deadpool 2
during the uh the jump scene where a
bunch of people yeah yeah yeah
uh and and there are so many great
people to choose from i i
do think that uh john cena as it is an
oath keeper or peacekeeper
i i think that there is a chance i i
knowing that character though i hope he
lasts longer uh same thing with flula's
character
i hope he lasts till like the trilogy is
over
um the character though that i think
makes the most sense
to die early on and in the most funny
weird way
is actually james gunn's brother sean
gunn
yeah uh sean gunn uh has has a density
to make an appearance on a lot of his
brother's stuff which is fantastic
um but any chan anytime uh family gets
the chance to kill family it's
only a positive win-win situation uh and
especially going back to their trauma
days that
you know that james has some idea it's
like dude what if we kill you with like
a
uh like a trip mine but only half your
body explodes and then the rest of your
body actually gets eaten by like a man
shark or something
and he's like that's a great idea so i
think that they just have so much fun
killing each other
and i think we'll we'll see sean gunn's
uh if i am to be is to be believed
in that case i think it's javelin who
also does die in the comics
and how javelin beats green lantern is
kind of beyond
me but you know leave deshawn gun to
figure out how to do it
i think that we will see his death near
the beginning of the movie because
honestly
he doesn't need the paycheck for like a
long movie time or anything he's still
living off those royalties of gilmore
girls on netflix
so he's sitting pretty on his mountains
of money and uh
he's just kind of like yeah i'll stop by
for a few minutes sure james
i'm in i'm in kill me off i'm loving the
scenario that sean gunn still like doing
his
uh little brother james gonna oh yeah
whatever guy
i'm so wealthy from gilmore girls
it's like what you're working with
marvel and dc sibling rivalry
yeah i don't know if that's how the
money's working i don't think netflix
pays
any actor that much but i do love that
idea and it makes a lot of sense to me
jovan so i'm awarding you one i'd award
you more but i just feel so bad for sean
gunn for having to play
rocket and sustain an actor for like
end game for infinity war for the
guardians movies
and he's man the knees on that guy i
can't even imagine these strengths he
must have from crouching around
so he deserves a bit more screw time uh
but you're getting one so there you go
i'll take the one and and as i uh reach
in uh i'd like you to stop handing me
sharp objects uh
more knives from my team days this one
has
flames on the side because i thought
that was cool uh
i had knives knives
i just recently got rid of my swords all
right we are now moving on to
rogue questions it is anyone's game here
in this episode of rogue theory
do it question one ryan reynolds
released a joke streaming service
mint mobile plus that only streamed one
movie his 2003
flick foolproof if you had a streaming
service with only one movie
what would that movie be i think it's
the greatest superhero movie of all time
shrek okay you can never get too much
shrek in your life
shrek is love shrek
and who is shrek the superhero of that
story
yeah maybe a donkey i don't know
i mean donkey talks shrek is just a
standard ogre before an unusual thing
has been applied
shrek might be the the straight man of
that movie fiona
he is a hero yeah fiona yeah yeah
the superhero right all right shrek's a
good option
what else who else i think i would have
to go with mandy
uh which came out a couple years ago
starring nicholas cage yeah yeah
it's possibly the greatest movie ever
made by people
um and which is why i think it deserves
its own streaming service i do believe
it's on
shutter right now so if you have that
platform so i would go check it out
there is
directed by panos cosmetos and it is
impossible to describe
other than the fact that uh nicholas
cage
takes some significantly altered
biker lsd uh which messes up his brain
and there is a chainsaw fight
between two people wielding chainsaws so
uh that's all you need to know and you
should go check it out
it's got everything you need yep like
the john wick pencil situation huh
yeah i mean yeah it's a lot it's a lot
weirder
it's a lot weirder a movie yeah okay
chainsaws are pretty
pretty wild yeah that's fair okay all
right jovan what do you think
uh i would actually one-up ryan reynolds
and kind of like throw ryan reynolds in
a ryan reynolds off
and give him uh another obscure ryan
reynolds movies that not a lot of people
saw but more people need to see which is
called voices uh it's a nice little
rom-com that you can watch during um
uh during october where ryan reynolds
plays an individual that uh
is not taking his medication and
actually uh has i guess like
schizophrenia
uh might be killing some people anna
kendrick is in it as well which makes it
ten times better uh but he's got like he
has a cat and a dog
and he hears voices from the cats and
the dog uh and the cat is like his like
evil demon on his
on the side and the dog is like the
angel uh oh my god it's a must watch i
saw it on netflix
it has to still be there but yeah i
would i'd give ryan reynolds a run with
his money
uh with his actual money and and have
voices yeah
well uh jovan dj you both gave excellent
recommendations that actually
would uh get me to purchase that
streaming app but angelica
you understand truly that shrek is love
and shrek is life
you understood the spirit of the game so
so you get a rogie for that
yay and it came out as another heart but
it's a it's a darker one
than this other one i love it thank you
you're welcome uh all right question two
astronomers say the star beetlejuice not
the same
spelling the star of beetlejuice not the
movies you get it you get the start
uh has uh it has appeared dimmer lately
because of a giant cloud of space
dust what did you do to release that
space dust
uh the thing is i actually said
beetlejuice three different times and
the star beetlejuice is actually where
beetlejuice the the the creature we'll
call him gets his power from
so as as he then gets brought down to
earth he pulls from the power of that
said star to exist
here on earth so beetlejuice walks among
us
you just created some beetlejuice lore
i'm very excited by this
i think we're looking at this the wrong
way i think we're talking about like oh
we can't see beetlejuice as well i think
beetlejuice has been seeing what's going
on on earth and he's just like nah
yeah he's staying away i don't need any
of that let's just cover that you know
like when you see a spot on the wall
you're like
i'm just going to move a plant in front
of it or something not worry about it
yeah yeah that's fair this space
dust is actually an entity
and it's really just galactus coming for
earth and
ready to contend in the apocalypse year
of 2020.
i think that's yeah i think that's what
it is i think he's coming
it's something something is coming i
think
i think dj's answer is the most accurate
i think there's some celestial bodies
out there they're like no thanks pass so
you get the point
oh thank you thank you thank you grab it
it's the superman car
wow
wow so many good things on the other
side
all right our final question uh speaking
of uh
some merch some toys toy maker infiniti
studios is releasing a life-sized
three thousand dollar jason mamoa
aquaman
torso statue complete with realistic
hair
and silicone skin what
activity would you like to do with your
life like
aquaman torso a non-sexual activity
you have to specify i have to i have to
i gotta say right off the bat i think
that's a trick question
because i think no matter anything you
do with it is immediately more sexual
because you've got a life like jason
momoa boss
so it's just you're saying non-sexual no
matter what you you could be you could
be watching what boiling yeah you're
gonna watch
netflix it's immediately netflix and
chill time that's you know you can't
help it
yeah you could be discussing abstinence
with that torso statue and it would
still be
too sexy sexual yeah uh i
i will wind up doing a little home alone
two parting
where i just put it in front of like a
stool that's actually kind of rotating
in front of the window with music
playing so people walking by it's like
is that jonah's place is jason momoa
partying
with jovenshire what
instant popularity points you you'd be
like
the best person on the block like you
you're the main character of your entire
street
yeah but everyone's like you know i
don't think mama really likes joking
because he just keeps staying in like
this far
corner of the house and won't move he's
a wallflower
it's fine you can explain it um
so i'm thinking that you know i'll
probably talk to it because quarantine's
been real lonely
but also maybe i'll put it on my car
like on the hood of my car and just
drive around
it's not safe but it's fun and i think
it would be real flashy
and it would it would make my 2020. it
would be super cool
it'd be like when chase momoa um teen
wolf the batmobile in uh
just asleep yeah just put on the hood of
my car and just have to like look around
cameo and mad max when he's on the uh
yeah and then i'll get up on the back of
the car like mad max and or
i guess the front and just start playing
guitar yeah exactly
yeah yeah who's driving this thing and
then i'll braid his hair
sometimes yeah it would be fun uh three
great answers but i gotta give the point
to uh joven for finding a practical use
for
the completely impractical home alone uh
wet bandits trick
[Laughter]
i'll take that point and it uh it
actually comes out as uh
uh i'll take that point and it's ah an
empty bottle of whiskey
come on dude oh really make sure it's
full next time
i'm very concerned you got knives you
had to get rid of swords and you have an
empty bottle of whiskey
what is going down in the juventus you
should be
concerned quarantine has been a real
long time over here
oh boy uh well jovan i'm afraid to ask
you what your wish
is but you did win this episode so um
what is your wish oh uh my wish is going
back to my uh
totally accurate uh um reveal of dan
devito coming back as
as the penguin and in your best batman
impersonation i need you to tell
uh the penguin that he's going to be
brought down and brought to justice
which batman
any batman of your choice okay um let's
see
i will do the uh i'll do adam west
batman
hey penguin your days are numbered
and i'm afraid that it's going to be
back to
antarctica for you is that adam west
this is good that was good i'll give it
up i'll give you a good clap yeah
he'd be proud well i just really want to
do like penguin hands they're like this
right or they like
can you imagine doing a whole movie like
that and then just stuck in these gloves
yeah and he's in crafties they just
they accidentally like he can't take the
gloves off he's like stuck at crafty's
trying to eat like this with like
lobster claws i think they're like
danny devito has a feeder on set someone
comes around just feeding you yeah
i volunteer yeah i volunteer
it's always sunny it's always everywhere
it goes well that is it for this episode
of rogue theory i want to thank our
guests
uh uh joshua ovenshire jovan thank you
for joining us this week
always a pleasure uh do you guys check
me out online and stuff at the job and
share that's right uh and
hey trey angelica yeah
thank you for having me it was always i
mean as always it's great talking with
you guys and feel free to check out
all you know my other social medias um
including twitch at a tray and my
instagram angelica tray
and uh thank you for coming back and
joining us today dj wooldridge
of course thank you for having me you
can find me at dj talks trash every
place that matters and please
check out only stupid answers wherever
you get podcasts or on youtube
uh we're doing new content all the time
including lovecraft country reviews
ooh oh god i love that show hopefully
i'd love to talk about that more that's
that's amazing uh check that out check
out that show that's it's it's so
awesome if you haven't seen it yet
uh well thank you again to everyone for
watching and for um
and for sticking around this far we know
most people don't get all the way to the
end of the episode but those of you who
do
are special ones deep in our hearts
don't forget to subscribe to the rogue
theory podcast feed and stay tuned
to the youtube channel for this and
other shows follow us on twitter and
social media
at new rockstars follow me at eavos and
we'll see you next week
stay safe out there wear a mask
[Music]
you